This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a pretty famous novel about the old American West called Lonesome Dub. Published in 1985, it won a Pulitzer Prize and was later made into a TV miniseries. It's one of the best books ever written, I think. That's our own Katie Mingle. So in the book, a group of cowboys from Texas, cattlemen, as they were once called, drives a huge herd of cattle through the great open west, all the way from Texas up to Montana.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。有一部关于美国旧西部的著名小说叫《孤独之鸽》。它出版于1985年，曾获得普利策奖，后来被改编成电视迷你剧。我认为这是有史以来写得最好的书之一。那是我们的凯蒂·明格尔。书里讲的是一群来自德克萨斯州的牛仔——当时被称为牧牛人——赶着一大群牛，穿过广阔的西部，从德克萨斯一直走到蒙大拿。
It's an epic adventure story. The writing is just gorgeous. Here's a passage. As they rode north, they saw more buffalo, mostly small bunches of 20 or 30. The third day north of the Yellowstone, they killed a crippled buffalo calf and dined on its liver. In the morning, when they left, there were a number of buzzards and two or three prairie wolves hanging around waiting for them to leave the carcass. It was a beautiful morning, crisp for an hour or two, and then sunny and warm.
这是一个史诗般的冒险故事。文笔非常优美。这里有一段摘录：当他们向北骑行时，他们看到了更多的野牛，大多是20到30头一群的小群体。在黄石公园以北的第三天，他们杀死了一头瘸腿的野牛犊，并享用了它的肝脏。早晨他们离开时，有几只秃鹫和两三只草原狼在周围徘徊，等着他们离开尸体。那是一个美丽的早晨，清爽了一两个小时，然后变得阳光明媚，温暖宜人。
The country rolled on to the north, as it had for thousands of miles, brown in the distance. The prairie grasses waving in the breeze. The book, which is fiction, takes place in the 1870s. And the reason we're talking about it is that basically everything about that scene was about to become impossible. The whole premise of the book really was about to become impossible. In just a few years, cattle drives would come to an end.
大地向北延伸，就像几千英里以来那样，远处呈现出一片棕色。草原上的草在微风中摇曳。这本书是虚构的，故事发生在19世纪70年代。我们谈论它的原因是，那个场景中的一切基本上都即将变得不可能。整本书的前提实际上都即将变得不可能。仅仅几年后，赶牛活动就将走向终结。
The west would become populated with people and towns and railways, and almost all of the buffalo would be gone. This change would come about incredibly quickly, and a lot of it would be brought about by one very simple invention that would come to be known as the Devil's Rope. But let's back up, just a tad. In the mid-1800s, not many non-native Americans had ever been west of the Mississippi. When Frederick Law Olmsted visited the west in the 1850s, he remarked that it was like a sea of grasses
西部将住满居民、城镇和铁路，几乎所有的野牛都将消失。这种变化发生得极其迅速，其中很大一部分是由一项非常简单的发明带来的，这项发明后来被称为“魔鬼之绳”。但让我们稍微回顾一下。在19世纪中期，很少有非原住民美国人去过密西西比河以西。当弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德在19世纪50年代访问西部时，他评论说那就像一片草的海洋，
that moved and swells after a great storm. And they were so tall that in order to see where you are or to get your bearings, you had to stand on a horse's back. That's Joanne Lou. Hi, my name is Joanne Lou. I am a Texas-based writer and editor. You had to go far west. You had to go to the west coast to Washington, Oregon, California to see more settlers out there.
在暴风雨后起伏涌动。草长得太高了，以至于为了看清你在哪里或辨别方向，你必须站在马背上。那是乔安妮·卢。嗨，我叫乔安妮·卢。我是一名常驻德克萨斯的作家和编辑。你必须走得很远，必须去西海岸的华盛顿州、俄勒冈州、加利福尼亚州，才能看到更多的定居者。
The middle of the country was divided into territories. And apart from Texas, most of the land was owned by the federal government. On the maps up until I would say about 1850s, 1840s, they just labeled that whole region as a great American desert. They later changed the maps to say the great American planes, but still, the middle of the country was a vast unknown. It was sparsely populated, mostly by Native Americans and by Catelman who were supplying beef to the people on the East Coast. And then in the mid-1800s, people in the East start thinking about manifest destiny and about settling the West. The American government wanted to settle the American West, and they didn't view Catelman
国家中部被划分为领地。除了德克萨斯州，大部分土地归联邦政府所有。在19世纪50年代、1840年代之前的地图上，他们只是把整个地区标注为“大美洲沙漠”。他们后来把地图改成了“大美洲平原”，但国家中部仍然是一片广阔的未知地带。那里人口稀少，主要是美洲原住民和为东海岸人民供应牛肉的牧牛人。然后在19世纪中期，东部的人们开始考虑“昭昭天命”和定居西部。美国政府想要定居美国西部，他们并不认为牧牛人
and Native Americans as suitable settlers of the West. What they wanted out there were people who would actually farm the land, put down the roots, improve the land with buildings and communities, and they looked to the Yomon farmer to do that. Ye old Yomon farmer. So in 1862, President Lincoln signs the Homestead Act, which basically says if he move west and settle on a piece of land that we stole from other people and farm it, and you do that for five years, the land is yours, 160 acres free for the taking. And so of course, the yeoman, you know, us common folk, started heading west. Free land, that can't be hard, right? Right? Guys? I seem like a great idea. They really didn't think about how difficult that would be for
和美洲原住民是合适的西部定居者。他们想要的是那些真正会耕种土地、扎根、用建筑和社区改善土地的人，他们寄希望于自耕农来做这件事。古老的自耕农。所以，1862年，林肯总统签署了《宅地法》，基本上是说，如果你搬到西部，在从别人那里偷来的土地上定居并耕种，而且你这样做满五年，这片土地就是你的，160英亩免费获取。当然，自耕农，也就是我们这些普通人，开始向西进发。免费的土地，那应该不难吧？对吧？伙计们？这看起来是个好主意。他们真的没考虑过这对
people going out there. No towns, no roads, no stores, no schools. And of course, no fencing material. And it turns out fences were crucial to farmers, but that sea of grasses was not a sea of fencing materials. In other words, there weren't many trees to use for lumber. Yeah, the sothers started going out there and what they found was that the land was fertile. It was great for farming, but there was cattle everywhere. And so when they started to plant their crops,
去那里的人来说有多困难。没有城镇，没有道路，没有商店，没有学校。当然，也没有围栏材料。事实证明，围栏对农民至关重要，但那片草海并不是围栏材料的海洋。换句话说，没有多少树木可以用来做木材。是的，定居者开始去那里，他们发现土地很肥沃。非常适合耕种，但到处都是牛。所以当他们开始种植庄稼时，
the cattle would just simply wander onto the fields, trample, and destroy all their efforts. To keep cattle out of their crops, the farmers tried using these really thick and thorny osage orange hedges for fencing. They worked pretty well, but they took five years to grow. And if you had to move the boundaries of your property, tough luck.
牛就会直接漫步到田里，践踏并摧毁他们所有的努力。为了把牛挡在庄稼地外，农民们尝试使用这种非常厚且多刺的橙桑树篱笆来做围栏。它们效果不错，但需要五年才能长成。如果你必须移动你的财产边界，那就倒霉了。
Settlers also tried smooth wire fencing, but the cattle could just bust right through it. Everyone was getting really frustrated. A lot of settlers, they moved west and found that they had this problem on their hands, and there was nothing they could do about it, and then they left. Fencing became an issue of much discussion.
定居者也尝试过光滑的铁丝围栏，但牛可以直接冲过去。每个人都感到非常沮丧。许多定居者搬到西部，发现他们面临这个问题，却无能为力，于是他们离开了。围栏成了一个讨论很多的话题。
There was talk about everywhere you went. Among farmers of course, but also in newspapers, agricultural publications, and in the US government. The US Department of Agriculture, though, I think, was the land office, did a study in 1870, and they basically determined that it was not feasible to set all the West because there was no fencing. It was impossible. Our destiny could not be manifested without solving the fencing problem. And the solution, barbed wire. There were a lot of different patents filed for barbed wire-like fences around this time,
无论你走到哪里，都有人在谈论。当然是在农民中间，还有报纸、农业出版物和美国政府中。不过，我认为美国农业部（当时是土地局）在1870年做了一项研究，他们基本上确定，定居西部是不可行的，因为没有围栏。这是不可能的。如果不解决围栏问题，我们的天命就无法实现。解决方案是：带刺铁丝网。当时有很多关于带刺铁丝网类围栏的专利申请，
many of which attempted to replicate the deterrent properties of the thorn bush. Ultimately, the barbed wire design that prevailed was from a guy named Joseph Glidden. In 1873, Glidden was at a county fair in his hometown of Decav Illinois when he saw a fence that inspired him. It was like a strip of wood with nail-like spikes on it. The strip of wood was meant to be attached to a smooth wire fence. And he realized he could improve on that. Couldn't win home and created what we now know as barbed wire. Sharp metal barbs twisted around a strand of smooth wire. And from then he intertwined a second smooth piece of wire so that the twisted
其中许多试图复制荆棘丛的威慑特性。最终，胜出的带刺铁丝网设计来自一个叫约瑟夫·格利登的人。1873年，格利登在他家乡伊利诺伊州迪卡尔布的一个县集市上看到了一种启发他的围栏。那是一条带有钉子状尖刺的木条。木条本意是附在光滑的铁丝围栏上。他意识到他可以改进它。他回家后创造了我们现在所知的带刺铁丝网。锋利的金属刺缠绕在一股光滑的铁丝上。然后他缠绕了第二根光滑的铁丝，这样扭曲的
barbs could not slide around. Glidden went into business with a guy named Isaac L. Wood and they said about trying to get barbed wire into the hands of Western settlers. But people were skeptical that barbed wire would work against the kind of cattle they were raising in the West at the time. The Texas Longhorn. Texas Longhorn's were the most unruly, belligerent cattle. And so the idea that this little piece of Barb Dweyer could keep them out of anywhere was just laughable.
刺就不会四处滑动。格利登与一个叫艾萨克·L·埃尔伍德的人合伙做生意，他们着手尝试将带刺铁丝网送到西部定居者手中。但人们怀疑带刺铁丝网是否对当时他们在西部饲养的那种牛有效。德克萨斯长角牛。德克萨斯长角牛是最不听话、最好斗的牛。所以，这种小小的带刺铁丝网能把它们挡在任何地方的想法简直是可笑的。
So the story goes that Gliddenon Lwood sent a fast-hocking salesman and compulsive gambler known as John Betamillion Gates down to San Antonio to sell barbed wire. And Betamillion Gates basically tells all the farmers and cowboys to gather at their most unruly cattle and stick them inside this barbed wire enclosure that he built in the town square. By the end of day, there was a huge crowd.
故事是这样的，格利登和埃尔伍德派了一位口才极佳的推销员和赌徒，人称“百万富翁”约翰·盖茨，去圣安东尼奥推销带刺铁丝网。这位“百万富翁”盖茨基本上告诉所有的农民和牛仔，把他们最不听话的牛聚集起来，关进他在城镇广场建造的这个带刺铁丝网围栏里。到了一天结束时，那里聚集了巨大的人群。
They put the cattle in the enclosure and they got them all riled up. And the cattle just went crazy. They rushed up against the fence and immediately reared back because they met up with the barbed wire. Eventually, the cattle all just kind of neatly settled down. Better milling gate started taking orders right then there.
他们把牛放进围栏里，把它们激怒了。牛群变得疯狂起来。它们冲向围栏，但因为碰到了带刺铁丝网，立刻向后退缩。最终，牛群都安静了下来。这位“百万富翁”盖茨当场就开始接订单了。
Word spread and sew did the barbed wire all over the west. In 1874 when Glidden and Elwood first started they produced 10,000 pounds of barbed wire. 1876 which is the same year that Betty Milling gates went to San Antonio. They were producing nearly 3 million pounds of barbed wire. Before barbed wire hit the west, the cattlemen had just been kind of watching and laughing as the yeoman farmers struggled with their bench rubs. Remember, the west before the Homestead Act was in large part populated by cattlemen and
消息传开了，带刺铁丝网也传遍了整个西部。1874年，当格利登和埃尔伍德刚开始时，他们生产了1万磅带刺铁丝网。1876年，也就是“百万富翁”盖茨去圣安东尼奥的那一年，他们生产了近300万磅带刺铁丝网。在带刺铁丝网进入西部之前，牧牛人一直看着并嘲笑着自耕农在他们的荆棘丛中挣扎。记住，在《宅地法》颁布之前，西部在很大程度上是由牧牛人和
the various Native American tribes. And though a lot has been made of the animosity between cowboys and Indians, they had this one kind of striking thing in common. Neither really believed in fencing off the land and hanging no trespassing signs. The west of the American cowboy before the homestead act was governed by something called the law of the American cowboy before the homestead act was governed by something called the law of the open range. Now I always thought that the open range was a figure of speech, like it just meant big
各种美洲原住民部落居住的。虽然牛仔和印第安人之间的敌意被大肆渲染，但他们有一个惊人的共同点。双方都不太相信把土地围起来并挂上“禁止入内”的牌子。在《宅地法》颁布之前，美国牛仔的西部是由所谓的“开放牧场法”管理的。我一直以为“开放牧场”是一个比喻，就像它只是指大的
open pastors, but nope, it was like the way things were done. It was a big deal in the West, so it just became practice, a common practice that became unwritten code of law. Cattle need to range far and wide to fatten up. And for cattle to get the grazing lands they needed, the land had to be open. So you can probably guess who was about to ruin everything. Ye old yeoman farmer and their barbed wire fences. It was in direct contradiction of the law, the open range.
开放牧场，但不是，它是做事的方式。这在西部是一件大事，所以它成了一种惯例，一种成为不成文法典的共同做法。牛需要大范围地游荡才能长肥。为了让牛获得它们需要的放牧地，土地必须是开放的。所以你可能猜到谁即将毁掉一切了。古老的自耕农和他们的带刺铁丝网围栏。这直接违背了开放牧场法。
Apart from that, people also thought that barbed wire was cruel. A lot of the cattle, you know, they would be injured by the barbed wire, and their wounds would become infested with screwworm, and they would die. A whole side business of elixirs for wounded cattle sprung up. Briefly, people tried designing more humane barbed wire fences. They were made to be easier for the cattle to see and avoid, but they didn't catch on.
除此之外，人们还认为带刺铁丝网很残忍。很多牛，你知道，会被带刺铁丝网弄伤，伤口会感染螺旋蝇蛆，然后它们就会死掉。一种专门为受伤牛只提供药剂的副业应运而生。人们曾短暂地尝试设计更人道的带刺铁丝网围栏。它们被设计得更容易让牛看到并避开，但并没有流行起来。
In any case, the cattlemen weren't happy. If you've ever seen the musical Oklahoma, and oh, I have, you might remember this little ditty called The Farmer and the Calman should be friends. I don't know. I'd like to say a word for the farmer. Let's say it! He come out western made a lot of changes.
无论如何，牧牛人并不高兴。如果你看过音乐剧《俄克拉荷马》，哦，我看过，你可能还记得这首叫《农民和牧牛人应该成为朋友》的小曲。我不知道。我想为农民说一句话。说吧！他来到西部，做出了很多改变。
He come out western build a lot of fences. And build them right across our cattle ranges. Why those dirtstrasches go back to Missouri? Wait a minute, Alonso! The chorus of the song implores all territory folks to stick together. But in reality, cowboys and farmers wouldn't become friends for a while. The cattlemen resented the farmers as they put up more and more fences. And that's what set off the defense-cutting wars.
他来到西部，建造了很多围栏。并把它们建在我们的牧牛场上。为什么那些乡巴佬不回密苏里去？等等，阿隆索！这首歌的合唱恳求所有领地的人团结一致。但实际上，牛仔和农民在很长一段时间内都不会成为朋友。随着农民竖起越来越多的围栏，牧牛人对他们产生了怨恨。这就是引发“围栏切割战争”的原因。
The fence-cutting war. They started around 1881. It began with cowboys cutting down illegal fences. The people were putting up around land that they didn't even have a rightful claim on. What happened was as this sort of momentum built, a lot of people started joining in a lot of outlaws and rustlers, and they started cutting illegal and illegal fences and then cut them and followed suit. And it just erupted in chaos.
围栏切割战争。它们始于1881年左右。起初是牛仔们砍断非法围栏。人们在他们甚至没有合法所有权的土地周围竖起围栏。发生的事情是，随着这种势头的建立，许多人开始加入，许多不法之徒和偷牛贼，他们开始砍断非法和合法的围栏，然后跟风。这简直演变成了一场混乱。
Starting in Texas and it spread northwards all the way up to Montana. The cowboys cut fences at night with masks on. They even had fence cutting gangs with names like the owls, the blue devils, and the land leak. This all went on for about four years. Most of the damage was in property value, but there are a few deaths on record. Eventually, the Texas State government and the feds got involved, and the fence cutting finally died down around 1885. During the 1800s, the buffalo that roamed the American West died off in huge numbers, partly
从德克萨斯州开始，一直蔓延到北部的蒙大拿州。牛仔们在晚上戴着面具砍断围栏。他们甚至有围栏切割团伙，名字叫“猫头鹰”、“蓝魔”和“土地泄漏”。这一切持续了大约四年。大部分损失是财产价值方面的，但也有几起死亡记录。最终，德克萨斯州政府和联邦政府介入，围栏切割战争在1885年左右终于平息。在19世纪，漫游在美国西部的野牛大量死亡，部分原因是
because settlers were killing them for their hides, but also because of fences. Buffalo needed large areas for their migration. And just like it did for the cattle, barbed wire impeded the buffalo's access to grazing lands and water. Before white people lived in the West, it's estimated that 65 million buffalo live there, but by the end of the 1800s. They were less than a thousand.
定居者为了皮毛而猎杀它们，但也因为围栏。野牛需要大面积的区域进行迁徙。就像对牛群一样，带刺铁丝网阻碍了野牛进入放牧地和水源。在白人居住在西部之前，据估计有6500万头野牛生活在那里，但到了19世纪末，它们只剩下不到一千头。
By the time barbed wire hit the West, a lot of Native American tribes had already been forced onto reservations, but some were still relatively free, living a nomadic lifestyle that followed the migration of the buffalo. And so of course the Native cultures also lived by the law of the open range, even if they didn't call it that. And once the bar wire went up, for the Native Americans, the way of life was just obliterated. Native Americans ultimately came to refer to the fencing as the Devil's Rope. By the end of the century, the West was basically covered in the Devil's rope. The fence-cutting wars were over, the farmers had won.
当带刺铁丝网进入西部时，许多美洲原住民部落已经被迫进入保留地，但有些仍然相对自由，过着跟随野牛迁徙的游牧生活。所以当然，原住民文化也遵循开放牧场法，即使他们不这样称呼它。一旦带刺铁丝网竖起来，对于美洲原住民来说，他们的生活方式就被彻底摧毁了。美洲原住民最终开始把这种围栏称为“魔鬼之绳”。到世纪末，西部基本上被“魔鬼之绳”覆盖了。围栏切割战争结束了，农民们赢了。
Even the cowboys had come to accept and use barbed wire. And then barbed wire finds a whole new purpose. Then it moves from an agricultural economy, as it were, to a very specific political military economy. That's Alan Crel. Hi, my name is Alan Crel and I'm the author of The Devil's Rope, a cultural history of Bob Wire. Alan says that World War One is the first time barbed wire really becomes widely associated with being a tool of war. So if you could imagine, trench warfare had a remarkable intimacy to it.
甚至牛仔们也开始接受并使用带刺铁丝网。然后带刺铁丝网找到了一个全新的用途。它从一种农业经济，变成了某种特定的政治军事经济。那是艾伦·克雷尔。嗨，我叫艾伦·克雷尔，我是《魔鬼之绳：带刺铁丝网的文化史》的作者。艾伦说，第一次世界大战是带刺铁丝网真正与战争工具广泛联系在一起的第一次。所以如果你能想象，堑壕战有一种非凡的亲密感。
You had a line of trenches. And then just a hundred yards away, the enemy had their own line of trenches. And the area in between is so-called no man's land. And on either side of this No Man's Land, there would be barbed wire fortifications. The barbed wire kept the enemy out of your trench, but soldiers got caught and sometimes died in it. There's a British army song from that time
你有一条战壕线。然后就在一百码外，敌人有他们自己的战壕线。中间的区域就是所谓的“无人区”。在这个无人区的两侧，会有带刺铁丝网防御工事。带刺铁丝网把敌人挡在你的战壕外，但士兵们会被困在里面，有时会死在里面。当时有一首英国军歌
that captures this called the Old Barbed Wire. There ain't no be Old Barbed Wire. We sing that, we sing that, We sing that, we sing that, We sing that, we sing that, Barbed Wire shows up again in World War II, with an extra sinister innovation. Electrified, Barbed wire is a double horror. Electrified, Barbed wire was part of the architecture of the Holocaust.
捕捉到了这一点，叫《旧带刺铁丝网》。没有旧带刺铁丝网。我们唱这个，我们唱这个……带刺铁丝网在第二次世界大战中再次出现，并带有一种额外的邪恶创新。通电的带刺铁丝网是双重恐怖。通电的带刺铁丝网是大屠杀建筑的一部分。
It was such a ubiquitous part of the scenery that, in fact, there was a term coined in the Death Camps of World War II for committing suicide by throwing oneself on the electric fence. Embracing the wire remarkable. Embracing the wire. In the 1960s you get Barbed wire's evil spawn razor wire, also called ribbon wire. And of course now you see that stuff that prisons all over the world. Baubwire is nasty. It's menacing. It's transparently terrible.
它是风景中如此普遍的一部分，事实上，在第二次世界大战的死亡集中营中，有一个词专门用来形容通过投向电网来自杀的行为。拥抱铁丝网，非凡。拥抱铁丝网。在20世纪60年代，你得到了带刺铁丝网的邪恶后代——刀片刺网，也叫丝带铁丝网。当然，现在你在世界各地的监狱里都能看到那种东西。带刺铁丝网很讨厌。它具有威胁性。它透明地可怕。
As useful as the fencing may have been to farmers and to settling the West, Alan says that barbed wire has always been about control and possession and separation. That keeps it and it keeps it. Except for once. There's one instance where the stuff was actually used not to separate us, but to connect us. Right around the same time that Barb Wire was invented, Alexander Graham Bell received a patent for an apparatus for transmitting vocal or other sounds telegraphically. The telephone, basically. And as telephone companies went about stringing telephone wires
尽管这种围栏对农民和定居西部可能很有用，但艾伦说，带刺铁丝网一直都是关于控制、占有和分离的。它保持着它，它保持着它。除了有一次。有一次，这种东西实际上不是用来分离我们，而是用来连接我们。就在带刺铁丝网发明的同时，亚历山大·格拉汉姆·贝尔获得了一项通过电报传输声音或其他声音的装置的专利。基本上就是电话。随着电话公司开始架设电话线，
in cities, they weren't really interested in the rural market. But farmers wanted phones, needed them really, which meant they needed a network of wires that connected all the farms. I think you see where this is heading. Some very clever people said, well, we have wires already. We have these barbed wire fences.
在城市里，他们对农村市场并不感兴趣。但农民想要电话，确实需要它们，这意味着他们需要一个连接所有农场的电线网络。我想你明白这是什么意思了。一些非常聪明的人说，好吧，我们已经有电线了。我们有这些带刺铁丝网围栏。
That's David Cecilia. He's a professor of business and economic history at the University of Maryland. It wouldn't transmit a signal quite as clearly as say a nice insulated copper wire, but it worked. A dozen or so farms might connect to one telephone network, so for about 25 bucks households could buy a kit that included everything they need to rig themselves up to the system. To dry batteries, float short, ring condenser,
那是大卫·塞西利亚。他是马里兰大学的商业和经济史教授。它传输信号的效果不如那种好的绝缘铜线，但它确实有效。十几个农场可能会连接到一个电话网络，所以大约25美元，家庭就可以买到一个套件，包括他们把自己连接到系统所需的一切。干电池、浮动短路、铃声电容器、
magnet a lightning arrestor, 10 feet of interior wire, 50. Thousands of these rural, independent telephone collectives sprouted up all over the West and Midwest. In 1907, there were 18,000 cooperatives connecting an estimated million and a half rural households. Because of this, farmers ended up being the earliest adopters of telephone technology. In 1912, there were more farm households with telephones than non-farm households.
磁电机、避雷器、10英尺室内电线、50英尺……成千上万个这种农村独立电话合作社在西部和中西部各地涌现。1907年，有18,000个合作社连接了估计150万个农村家庭。正因为如此，农民最终成为了电话技术最早的采用者。1912年，拥有电话的农户比非农户多。
was a most unusual, but most inventive way of using the so-called devil's rope. By the 1930s, the National Bell Telephone System had penetrated into the remote rural regions of the West and Midwest. Farmers no longer had to create their own telephone collectives. And Barb Dwyer went back to doing what it does best. Keeping us in, keeping us out. 99% admissible was produced this week by Katie Mangle with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffelman, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to WF Strong for his reading of Lonesome Dove and for Haley Howell for Recording him. One part of the barbed wire story that we didn't explore is its wide representation in art and popular culture.
这是使用所谓的“魔鬼之绳”最不寻常但最有创造力的方式。到了20世纪30年代，国家贝尔电话系统已经渗透到西部和中西部的偏远农村地区。农民不再需要创建自己的电话合作社了。带刺铁丝网又回到了它最擅长的事情上。把我们关在里面，把我们挡在外面。《99%隐形》本周由凯蒂·明格尔制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁费尔曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。特别感谢WF·斯特朗对《孤独之鸽》的朗读，以及海莉·豪威尔为他录音。带刺铁丝网故事中我们没有探讨的一个部分是它在艺术和流行文化中的广泛表现。
Ellen Crull's book The Devil's Rope is a really great resource for this. It does seem to me to have an aesthetic character, a calligraphic character. If for one minute you can forget about all these other uses of pop wire and just look at the shapes. Joanne Loo, who you heard throughout the piece, wrote Barb wire the fence that changed the west. You can find links to both their books on our website. We are a project of 91.7 K.A.L.W. San Francisco and produced of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interiors firm in of ArcSide, an architecture and interiors firm, and beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
艾伦·克雷尔的书《魔鬼之绳》是这方面非常好的资源。在我看来，它确实有一种审美特征，一种书法特征。如果有一分钟你能忘记带刺铁丝网的所有这些其他用途，只看它的形状。你在整个节目中听到的乔安妮·卢写了《带刺铁丝网：改变西部的围栏》。你可以在我们的网站上找到他们两本书的链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在ArcSide的办公室制作，这是一家位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司。
You can follow along with my adventures at Ted on Facebook and Twitter, but the home of all things 99% invisible is 999PI.org. www.radiotepiotex you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我在TED的冒险，但所有《99%隐形》相关内容的大本营是99PI.org。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。